quand on compare ce qui s'est passé en
asie et en france par rapport à ce qui
risque d'arriver en afrique on voit que
très rapidement
ça va flamber
[Musique]
les premiers cas diagnostiqués
d'infection par le corona virus en
afrique remonte seulement à quelques
semaines et on voit que très rapidement
ces cas ont été diagnostiqués dont
quasiment la totalité des pays africains
mais ces cas ne représente que la partie
visible de l'épidémie la partie visible
de l'iceberg puisque faut pas oublier
que l'infection par un solo ce virus et
d'une infection avant tout bening pour
80% de la population et qui elle peut
passer inaperçu je pense que l'om mais
c'est tout à fait dans son rôle
lorsqu'elle de vendre au pays de se
préparer au pire on voit à quel point le
l'épidémie se développe de façon massive
sachant que l'on ne sait pas si le pire
est inéluctable c'est très difficile de
prévoir une épidémie a fortiori sur le
continent africain où des facteurs
environnementaux des facteurs
démographiques peuvent intervenir pour
que l'impact de l'épidémie sur les
populations soient pas exactement le
même que dans les pays occidentaux
l'enjeu de l'épidémie pour l'afrique ça
va être bien bien sûr la prise en charge
de la minorité
encore une fois c'est une minorité des
formes graves voire très sévère
ces fameux grave c'est environ 15%
qu'est ce que ça va être en afrique on
ne sait pas encore deux personnes qui
vont avoir des difficultés respiratoires
donc au passé le cap aiguë il faut
parfois une oxygénothérapie donc un
respirateur et c'est sûr que dans
beaucoup de pays africains il n'y a pas
assez de respirateurs puisque vont
arriver de façon massive à nombre
important de patients nécessitant un
respirateur pour passer un cap
début donc là c'est là où il va y avoir
un grand problème donc il faut vraiment
se focaliser sur la prise en charge de
ces patients graves fonctionnaires une
mettre en place une politique de
dépistage et de traitement rapide pour
ses formes qui risquent d' engager le
pronostic vital
on n'a pas encore de traitement
définitif bien s'il ya des des pistes
intéressantes comme celle de la
chloroquine médicaments disponibles en
afrique
encore une fois on n'a pas de certitudes
sur ce traitement mais ça vaut quand
même le
le goût de le tester et de l'évaluer
c'est dans un contexte africain on peut
également prévenir la maladie
un des grands enjeux de la prise en
charge de kobe en afrique qu'on a moins
en occident c'est comment ne pas
déstabiliser la prise en charge des
autres pathologies rapport au paludisme
au vih par rapport la tuberculose
le risque c'est que tout ce qu'on va
faire pour le coc vide ne bloque ne
désorganise la prise en charge de ces
maladies qui tuent encore plus que le
coc vide chez les enfants donc chez les
moins de 15 ans les ados jeunes ados et
chez des enfants
on n'a pas retrouvé de forme grave or la
population africaine est avant tout une
population jeune et c'est peut-être un
élément déterminant également sur
l'impact que pourrait avoir l'épidémie
en afrique
pourquoi parce que cette population
jeunes risquent de se contaminer très
rapidement de contaminer les autres mais
de développer ce qu'on appelle une
immunité c'est à dire des anticorps et
on sait que d'un point de vue
épidémiologique
arrivé à un certain niveau de protection
de la population grâce à ces anticorps
le virus et contrôlés
c'est peut-être faire ce que vous voulez
faire l'angleterre dans la phase
initiale de l'épidémie c'est à dire de
l'immunité collective
mais là dans un contexte où la
démographie nous le permet alors que en
angleterre comme il ya beaucoup de
personnes âgées comme partout en europe
le faire s'avérait être totalement
immoral compte tenu de l'impact que ça
aurait eu sur la population des
personnes âgées
l'immunité collective va pourrait
freiner l'impact de l'épidémie et
contrôler l'épidémie peut-être et c'est
encore une fois ce n'est qu'une
hypothèse mais il faut l'évaluer
contrôler l'épidémie de façon naturelle
entre guillemets par cette vaccination
naturel de masse créer un couloir
humanitaire est étudiée est une
nécessité et les pays se ferment et donc
comment faire pour que les pays puissent
avoir accès aux réactifs aux médicaments
par contre
un couloir humanitaire pour envoyer des
experts je crois que là il faut
peut-être s'appuyer sur les expériences
des pays
les ce2 aux experts que on en voit
régulièrement dont le continent africain
parfois son facteur de complication plus
que d'abord je suis un peu provocateur
mais les compétences dont les pays de la
plupart du temps sont là il ya eu
beaucoup d'épidémie et quand on voit par
exemple en rdc l'expérience des
collègues de l'hyène rb pour la
maîtriser l'épidémie
c'est plutôt eux qui ont des choses à
apprendre au continent plutôt que on
leur envoie des experts qui vont leur
faire perdre beaucoup de temps il faut
arrêter cette course à l'expert et au
père dit m il faut passer à autre chose
et s'appuyer sur les compétences réelles
qui existent sur le continent africain
[Musique]
mo